ils ont pesé sur diouf sur narwhal
voyons aujourd'hui on va être un arval
narvalo j'ai encore jamais joué à ce jeu
ça va être la toute première game avec
vous donc le but c'est de couper en deux
les autres ok en appuyant sur l'espace
tu mets un petit boost d'accélération
comme on dit dans we were attention à
toi garçons à l'époque ça marche bon là
on a vu les règles c'est fantastique
c'est participent aux propos bah oui oh
mon dieu ce qu'on lui a mis ces
pratiques alors ça fait à base de cris
comme d'habitude en ce que des connards
me dis [ __ ] comme les huits smith est
un bon connard ça joue physique attendue
en bas aux yeux un bug [ __ ] mecs
j'adore les bugs etc à toi volume des
coups comme il a fait ça au en fait je
pense que tu peux tourner d'un coup et
te booste et trois claques ou la peur
voire secours aux [ __ ] mes mecs mais
ils ont trop chaud
leaderboard mais un nouvel 28 mai
comment il a fait ça c'est lui c'est le
bel le jaune la mecque je vais la voir
je ne vis que pour le tuer à temps
j'aurais dû faire une collatéral là
j'aurais dû faire à double canon mais
d'où vous c'est n'importe quoi j'aurais
dû couper deux mille fois faith evans
bonne blague mais non au oui quand je
lis contre avec mon bec
ok en fait tout se joue avec le bec
moyens le mec bateau à aubes top je fais
des coupés [ __ ] mais bd vous tiens je
me retourne et blanc oh là là je me
retourne et c'est fantastique au nom aux
yeux c'était tellement beau
et
ligue a choisi bien et raté un match qui
vient
c'est le revers de la veille est engagé
au aulas a bien joué alors monsieur ça
arrive de partout mais la map est trop
petit la map est trop petit dicle aux
carrières du mirobolant les mecs on est
chaud là on joue dans life en fait il
faut le milieu de la mode étaient
tellement aux jobs
voilà c'est fait moi je vais longer les
bords mais je pense à tes 10 et de
longer les bords oui si de putois et
manta qui nouveaux essais ratés mais
allez rater de [ __ ]
quoi quoi au fait pas un bon tu sais
comme quand une voiture se met sur deux
roues pour passer entre deux autres
voitures quoi c'était base on est au
target est mort
tu première du problème je ne veux pas
sa mort je mange pas mais tu fuck merde
chez v ner il m'a mis trop mal ce
batteur joe cole à tous
ah non tu es je me sens un peu
persécutés palmito mais tout en finesse
naïve et c'est comme ça qu'on fait les
belles choses tout en chante limite à
quelques mois au tu fais quoi c'est quoi
c'est au moins la chance que tu as toi
oh oui oh oui oui c'est raté en premier
hall et non sous nos yeux au nom des
membres équipe est là qui est là qui a
fait quoi lui à toi et juste pour
arriver le four dans un coin la map je
vais si tu vois là où l on s'appelle le
fond tu fais quoi toi exactement comment
ont-ils fait voilà avec un patois le 1er
mai qui fait des effets désastreux
ce colloque est un verbe haut il ya le
label mec lui il est a noté ian gillan
on veut tous avoir gardé commandes
suivent bien l'a promis il fuit le mec
il fuit les premiers veut plus jouer
gardez-les vient de battre mon gardien
bon je m'en fous les mâconnais
techniques défensives moi jamais moi
jamais moi j'avais moi j'avais bla
[ __ ] c'est nul tu fais quoi toi menu
c1 ou lui aussi tu fais quoi arrêter les
ja arrêté voilà on est enfin samuel est
d'accord de la joie je sais pas s'il y
avait le roi le roi le roi focus leroy
situe entre nous l'a donc on pourrait
faire un coup d'état est renversée avant
l'archipel là ok ça c'est fait je le roi
voilà j tu cing h le roi alors là mais
qu'on veut c'est de conserver la
couronne mais pendant des années on est
tellement level nouvelle 30 donné aucun
nom
il est où le responsable et la cie
injustice que justice soit faite [ __ ]
en fait si chaud que constitue un mec
est nouvelle un refus gagnent qu'un
nouvel or quand tu es un gros chat eux
qui tuent un gars qui est nouvelle chez
pas combien tu gagnes tout c'est le même
jeu coupe pas du tout monde et il est
pas aiguisé pour ma défense n'est il pas
du tout ils disaient oh là on le roi au
nom
oui moi je me cassais trois jours ici au
nom mais l'écart est alors ouais
pourquoi personne veut tuer le roi on a
journée tranquille
voilà au le roi vient le roi les gars il
faut viser le haut il faut viser la
monarchie c'est lui qui l'a eue faut
voir michel bouvard michel ue avec c'est
quoi ce délire hockey des amis là la
joue enfin coup de chaud désastreux ça
veut dire que en fait un carnage playes
lou leroy qui convient la vie cola
arrêtez les gars on s'en fout de nous il
faut tuer le roi il a hier mais quoi
mais je suis outré mais comme tout mais
c'est quoi c'était aller il s'est fait
tuer fils de [ __ ] a regretté morse et
benjamins 1 il est au benjamin benjamin
au nom au nom mais target de même
connaît pas produit mais pète les
couilles
le 1er juillet la commune nous a détruit
hier au nom alain le roy
il nous a tellement tu es arnaud quand
on a pu faire ça à renouveler ou non
mais d'où je n'ai pas eu la renommée lui
quand je me suis je me suis je suis si
on l'a les liens à la taille va pousser
foutu et arnaud
officieusement sur target c'est parfait
si depuis je me casse sur mon cas je me
casse les c mois et coûteront au plat je
suis dans la monarchie vous êtes dans la
démocratie
non non c'est qu'on fait démocratie
maintenant
l'agencé a procédé sur nar voile vonn
bon à la mx2 narwhal énorme il est
excellent et passe dans le top 3 avec
égards poigne le slider priori les mêmes
devant lui parce qu'en fait il est hyper
rapide paru le 1er très très vite et de
faire détrôner encore plus vite alors
certains de nos prochaines de merci
d'avoir regardé portez vous bien chaude
pisse